So welcome back.
Hopefully you guys took
maybe a little break,
did something else.
Now we are going to talk about
normocytic and macrocytic
anemias. This is part two
of laboratory medicine
and anemias. And once again,
thank you Dr. Saggio for
all the help in generating
both of these lecture parts.
Once again, the offer
still stands. If
you have any questions
about anemia,
please feel free
to reach out to me.
And here are our
learning objectives.
They are the same as part one.
In our lecture layout, we
already discussed our general
concepts of anemia and
microcytic anemias. Now we
are going to discuss normo
and macrocytic anemias.
So let's start with
our macrocytic anemias.
Again, these are classified
as an MCV over 100.
So when we look at our
macrocytic anemias, we
can divide them out into
two separate categories,
megaloblastic and non
-megaloblastic anemias.
Megaloblastic simply means
that there is some issue in
DNA synthesis, and as a
result, you're going to see
hypersegmented neutrophils
on a peripheral blood smear.
Some of the causes of
megaloblastic anemia
include B9 deficiency,
B12 deficiency,
****** aciduria, something
that's less common but
still can be presented, and
also certain medications.
Non-megaloblastic anemia
simply means that we still
have these macrocytic or
large red blood cells,
but the DNA synthesis as
normal. These include things
like chronic alcohol use,
liver disease, diamond
black fan and anemia, and
also some drugs as well.
So let's first talk about
our megaloblastic anemias.
And again, the
underlying reasoning for
megaloblastic is an
impairment in DNA synthesis.
Some of the more common causes
are actually deficiencies
in both folate and B12,
which are essential in the
synthesis of DNA precursors.
And essentially to simplify
the pathways, folate likes
to move single carbon
groups, it circulates as
methyl tetrahydrofolate, and
essentially it likes to help
move homocysteine and convert
it to methionine by
transferring the single carbons.
B12 comes in and also
assists in this pathway
as well, and you'll kind
of understand why this
is important in
understanding it when we look
at these deficiencies
and the elevated markers.
So B12 will actually move
the methyl group off the
methyl tetrahydrofolate,
which again is where folate
comes in and converts
homocysteine to methionine.
So folate gives us the
carbon and B12 actually moves
it. And it's very important
that we generate this
methionine because it's a
precursor for DNA synthesis.
B12 is also an
important reactant and
intermediary step for the
methylmalonyl-CoA movement
to succinyl-CoA,
which helps with our
myelin synthesis. And
all of this text is kind
of simplified by this
graph to the right.
So to just continue a
little bit more with the
explanation of the biochemistry,
both folate and B12 are
very essential for the
synthesis of DNA precursors.
Without these DNA
precursors, the nuclei of the
rapidly dividing cells are
going to remain larger, right?
As the nuclei develop,
they condense the DNA into
smaller chromosomes, but
if we don't have these
precursors, we can't develop
these nuclei. These immature
nuclei do not have a lot
of DNA. As the DNA is
made, the nuclei become
smaller and more condensed.
This impaired division and
*********** in the red blood
cells, we therefore will
see the megaloblastic
anemia with very large
nuclei. This impaired division
and *********** in the
granulocytic precursors leads
to the hypersegmented
neutrophils that is very, very
common on any peripheral
blood smear. And as you can
see to the right here, this
is what we kind of talk
about with hypersegmented
neutrophil. We can count
all these different little
segments of the nuclei.
And again, these changes
can really be seen in any
rapidly dividing cell, and
you'll see a larger nucleus.
It's not necessarily unique
to just the neutrophils.
And also a little bit of
a connection that you guys
may kind of see a little bit
later on is homocysteine,
which will be elevated in
both the folate and B12
deficiency. If you look back
at the slide previously,
we move homocysteine to
methionine for DNA synthesis.
If you have elevated
homocysteine levels, you have an
increased risk of thrombosis
due to endothelial damage.
That also includes MIs,
also known as heart attacks.
So very simply, I want
to boil this all down in
some easy takeaways for you
guys. So B9, if folate is
deficient, there's an
elevation in homocysteine.
This is because methyl
tetrahydrofolate is a
reactant in that
homocysteine conversion to
methionine. If we don't
have this B9, we can't move
our carbons. If B12 is
deficient, there's also
going to be an elevation
in the homocysteine.
B12 helps the reaction from
homocysteine to methionine.
And if you can look
down here, kind
of on this biochemical pathway,
here's our B9, it becomes
tetrahydrofolate, it
moves around, it picks
up a methyl group, and
here's where a B12 comes
into handy, in this actual
conversion of the
homocysteine to methionine.
So if we're deficient in
either B9 or B12, this reaction
from homocysteine to
methionine will not happen.
So if we have a deficiency,
we'll see increased
levels of homocysteine in
both. But we can tell the
difference because in B12
deficiency, there's also
an increase in methylmalonyl
-CoA, and B12 helps
the reaction of methylonyl
-CoA to succinyl-CoA, which
is not something you
necessarily see down here,
but is something
to keep in mind. So
this little graph
down in the corner,
the big differentiator
is essentially
going to be our
methylonyl-CoA levels.
It will be elevated
in B12 deficiency,
but it will be normal
levels in B9 deficiency.
So let's start with macrocytic
anemias, folate deficiency.
So, dietary folate is
typically obtained from
green leafy vegetables and
fruits, and it's absorbed
mostly in the jejunum,
if you remember the
mnemonic from part one,
iron, fist, bro, folate
is fist, and then it's
the middle portion, so
in the jejunum, and we
typically have about a
few months of storage of
folate within the body.
The causes of the deficiency
can be a few different
reasons. It could be a poor
diet, so an elderly, a tea
and toast diet, or alcoholics.
Alcohol can actually block
the absorption of folate.
You can have an increased
demand, so pregnant women,
cancer, hemolytic anemias.
Also, some drugs,
methotrexate, can decrease B9.
Your clinical findings.
You can have a macrocytic
anemia and megaloblastic
anemia as well. You can
have those hypersegmented
neutrophils that we
talked about. Some other
findings that you may see
are glossitis, your folate
levels will be decreased,
your homocysteine levels
will be increased,
and your methylmalonic
acid levels will be normal.
Your B12 deficiency.
So B12 absorption is a
little bit more complex and
it's like to be examined
and questioned a little
bit more than folate
absorption. So first things
first, B12 is complex to
animal derived proteins.
If your patient is a true
vegan, has no dairy, no eggs,
and hasn't been consuming
these things for a couple
of years, you need to start
thinking about a potential
B12 deficiency if they
don't take any supplements.
So the pathway.
B12 travels to
the stomach where
it's eventually
cleaved by pepsin.
And again, just for your
knowledge, pepsin is
produced by chief cells
as pepsinogen, and then
it's activated by the
acidic environment in the
stomach. The salivary
gland also produces a
protein called R binder,
which helps to bind to
B12 once it's cleaved
from the animal protein.
The parietal cells actually
produce the intrinsic factor,
which are going to help
pick up the B12 once it's
cleaved from the R protein
by the pancreatic protease.
Once we are here, B12 binds
to the intrinsic factor
and that moves down the
jejunum into the terminal ileum
where it's eventually absorbed
in the terminal ileum.
So again, this picture is
really great. You can see
here the B12 is derived
to the animal protein. The
pepsin and the acidic
environment, which activates the
pepsin, will cleave the
protein off. Our factor picks
it up or R binder picks it up.
We then go to the pancreatic
protease that cleaves the
R protein off and picks
up intrinsic factor that
is produced by the parietal
cells. And then that B12
intrinsic factor moves down
into the terminal alium
where it's finally absorbed.
So B12 deficiency is actually
less common than folate
and simply because we have
years of B12 stored in the
liver versus months of
folate. So our major causes,
you could have a pure dietary
deficiency. So again, if
you have a pair of vegan
who's been vegan for multiple
years with no vitamin
supplementation think about b12
deficiency you could also
have pernicious anemia which
is actually the most common
cause and it's due to
autoimmune destruction of the
parietal cells if we don't
have these parietal cells
we can't produce intrinsic
factor and we'll also actually
have an increase in ph
so we can't really have
the b12 release from the
animal protein and even
if it was we wouldn't
have intrinsic factor to
pick it up once the b12
is cleaved from r binder
in the pancreas area
pancreatic insufficiency
if we don't have a
protease to cleave b12
from the r binder it can
never bind to intrinsic
factor think about your
chronic alcoholics with
pancreatic insufficiency
finally in the terminal
ileum you could have damage
via crohn's disease as well
as tapeworms and you could
also have other issues such
as bacterial overgrowth
So your lab findings
for B12 deficiency may
be a little bit similar
to folate deficiency.
You can have macrocytic
red blood cells
with hypersegmented
neutrophils,
right? This is a
megaloblastic anemia.
Your B12 levels should
be low. Your homocysteine
will be elevated, but
your methylmalonic acid
is also going to be
increased. And this is the
key differentiator
compared to B9 deficiency.
You'll also see
glossitis, but you'll also
have neurological
findings. you could have
something called sub-EQ
combined degeneration.
So with this, you're going
to have poor proprioception
and vibratory sensation
because you lose dorsal
columns, and you also
may have ******* pareases
because of the lateral
corticospinal tract destructions.
You also may have
dementia, and this is all
due to demyelination of the
posterior columns and the
lateral spinal tracts,
because again, we need B12
to produce myelin for the
central nervous system.
However, something to keep
in mind with treatment,
if you have these
neurologic findings and you
give an individual with
B12 deficiency folate, the
anemia actually will
resolve. So you can treat
B12 deficiency anemia
with folate. However, the
neurologic symptoms will
not resolve and they
actually could become worse.
So kind of a takeaway,
if you suspect there's either
a megaloblastic anemia,
you need to rule out a B12
deficiency before you just
give your patient folate and
hope it cures everything.
So just for a little bit
more a historical determining
source. There was something
called the Schillings
test and it was part of the
workup of B12 deficiency and
this was essentially to
determine if the body was
producing intrinsic factor
and if it could be absorbed.
So three stages
you use radioactive
B12 just to kind of
identify the B12.
The first part is you
give just radioactive
B12 without intrinsic
factor. Stage two is
with intrinsic factor and
stage three is without
intrinsic factor
after seven days of
antibiotics, or you can
give pancreatic enzymes.
If you see B12 in the
urine, we know the B12
is able to be absorbed.
If the B12 is not seen
in the urine, we know
B12 is not absorbed.
And if the B12 is only
present when we give the
intrinsic factor, we
actually know the issues with
intrinsic factor production,
such as pernicious
anemia. However, it's not
really used much anymore
because we are again
using radioactive B12, but
it's a good concept to
kind to test yourself
about understanding the
absorption process of B12.
So our next macrocytic
anemia is odorotic acid area.
Very simply, we still have
an issue with DNA precursor
production. However,
it's no longer a vitamin
issue. We now have an
inability to convert odorotic
acid to UMP due to a defect
in UMP synthase. Essentially,
it's an inability to
produce pyrimidines, which
we can't produce DNA synthesis
because that's one of
our precursors. It's an
autosomal recessive disease,
and the presentation is
usually a failure to thrive
in developmental delays.
Again, you're going to see
that megaloplastic anemia
not treated by folate or
B12 because, again, we
have an issue with creating
DNA, but it's not because
of a vitamin supplement
deficiency. And you're also
going to see ****** acid in
the urine, and treatment
is uridine monophosphate
or uridine triacetate to
bypass the mutated enzymes.
Again, this kind of just
finalizes the concept
of, again, macrocytic anemias
that are megaloblastic
is all because of
DNA synthesis issues.
So our non-megaloblastic
macrocytic anemias, the first
one being diamond black fan
anemia, and it's actually
a congenital defect. You
have pure red blood cell
aplasia, and it's an intrinsic
defect in the erythroid
progenitor cells leading
to a decrease in progenitor
cell numbers. So don't
worry too much about the
pathophys. This is more of
a clinical findings type of
diagnosis. You're going
to see rapid onset anemia
within their first year of
life and it's almost a triad
of short stature, craniofacial
abnormalities, and also
upper extremity abnormalities.
You can see triphalangeal
thumbs shown in this
photo down here. Your lab
findings, you're going to
see an increase in hemoglobin
F but a decrease in total
hemoglobin and the bone
marrow is also devoid of
red blood cell precursors.
The other causes, again
the key difference, we have
no issues with DNA
synthesis. You're not going
to see those hypersegmented
neutrophils but you
will still see macrocytic
red blood cells. The causes
include hemolysis or bleeding
causing reticulocytosis.
The bone marrow is
attempting to make more
red blood cells, Again,
pushing out those larger
immature reticulocytes
out into the circulation.
Alcohol can also cause
damage to the bone marrow,
and you could also have
liver disease. But I would
say overall, when we think
about macrocytic anemias,
I think the more important
ones to really nail down
will be those megaloblastic
anemias, in specific,
the B9 and B12 deficiencies.
So we've now finished our
macrocytic anemias. We have
now knocked out two of the
three types of anemias.
we're finally on normocytic.
However, I would love
to tell you guys that this
is the easiest and most
simple one to follow, but
unfortunately we have a lot
of different types and a lot
of different classifications
within normocytic, so
this may be a little bit
challenging. But I'm
going to try and walk you
through it as best I can,
and please again, if you guys
have any questions, feel
free to reach out. We can
talk about any of these
questions that you may have.
so again our normocytic
anemia the red blood cells
are normal in size and
normocytic anemia is actually
boiled down to one of two
options it's either an
underproduction of red blood
cells or an increased destruction
of red blood cells and
we actually determine the
cause via the reticulocyte
count so again just to
reiterate the reticulocytes
are those raw young red blood
cells released from the
bone marrow and on a
peripheral blood smear they're
going to appear as larger
kind of blue cytoplasm type
cells, and our normal count
is 1 to 2%. To determine if
this is an underproduction
or increased destruction
issue causing the normocytic
anemia, we actually
look at the corrected
reticulocyte count. So you
would expect if you have anemia,
your kidney will be signaling
to the bone marrow to
produce more red blood cells,
increasing the reticulocyte
count. So if we see a
corrected reticulocyte
count that is greater than
3, we know the issue is not
actually bone marrow,
right? The bone marrow has
responded to the signals to
produce more red blood cells,
therefore we know the bone
marrow is okay. We probably
should be looking somewhere
else for the issue of
this anemia, such as
destruction of red blood cells.
However, if the reticulocyte
count is not greater
than 3, so if it's less
than 3, we could actually
start to think about
the issue of this anemia
being with red blood
cell production itself.
The bone marrow is not
responding properly to this
anemia state and the
signals from the kidney via
EPO are not really
triggering a bone marrow
response starting to produce
more red blood cells.
So just some quick
terms you'll see on the
slide prior I talked about
corrected reticulocyte
count, and this is
simply, again, we want
to account for the anemia
that we have, right?
Reticulocyte count is shown
as a percentage of total
red blood cells. If the
individual is anemic,
they probably have a
decreased total number of red
blood cells. So how we
account for this, again, the
left side of this equation
is just reticulocytes over
total red blood cells.
The right side accounts
for hematocrit, which is,
again, the percentage of
red blood cells in the
blood over its normal value.
So again, this is just a
way to correct it. If we're
an anemic and we have a
reticulocyte count that
is 6%, but we actually
see that the hematocrit is
lower, we now have this 6%
times less than 1, so it's
going to correct it to a
lower reticulocyte value.
Again, not the most
important thing to
remember, but it is
important to just
think about these
things conceptually.
So we are going to start
with hemolytic anemias.
This means our corrected
reticulocyte count
is greater than 3%. So
hemolytic anemia, when we
think about it, it
means destruction of the
red blood cells. That's
what hemolysis is. And
there are a few terms we
could talk about here.
So the first one is intra
versus extravascular.
Intravascular meaning the
breakdown of the red blood
cells occur inside of
the blood vessels versus
extravascular where these
red blood cells are broken
down by that reticulo
-endothelial system which
are the macrophages of the
spleen, liver, and lymph
nodes. And if you guys
can recall from part one,
this RES system is
actually responsible
for normal red
blood cell turnover.
There's also two
other ways that we
could describe
hemolytic anemias.
Intrinsic meaning
there's an issue with the
actual red blood cell.
There's something wrong
with the membrane,
with maybe some of the
hemoglobins that's
causing this destruction.
Versus an extrinsic, the
red blood cell is okay, it's
perfectly normal, but
there's something else going
on in the body, whether that's
maybe calcified arteries
shearing the cells, or
an autoimmune attack of a
normal-looking red blood
cell. The commonalities
between the both of them.
You're going to see both in
intravascular and extravascular
hemolytic anemias, you're
going to see an increase
in lactate dehydrogenase,
which is just an enzyme
found in red blood cells.
And this should make sense.
If we're tearing open red
blood cells, you're going
to see their contents in
the blood. You'll also see
an increased reticulocyte
count because this is a
hemolytic anemia. The bone
marrow is able to respond
to this decreased red blood
cell count. You're also
going to see an unconjugated
bilirubin in both. However,
you'll see it a little bit
more in the extravascular.
And finally, you will
see pigmented gallstones, which
is again just a downstream
effect of the increase
of hemoglobin breakdown.
So let's start first with
extravascular hemolysis.
It again occurs in the
RAS system. And just in
general, every red blood
cell has to pass through
the spleen a few times a
day where it's inspected
by macrophages. You have
abnormal or old red blood
cells actually consumed by
these splenic macrophages,
where the globin from
hemoglobin is broken
down into amino acids, and
the heme is broken down
into its components of
iron and protoporphyrin.
Protoporphyrin is
further broken down into
unconjugated bilirubin,
where it's sent to the liver
attached to albumin for
conjugation and excretion.
You'll also see some of
the abnormal cells removed,
right? You could have
old cells or abnormal,
so spirocytes and sickle
cells, howl-jowl bodies,
and IgM and IgG attachment
to red blood cells,
and we'll talk about
what all this means in a
little bit. Your clinical
findings of extravascular
hemolysis, these are
important to keep in mind.
You're going to see
spirocytes on peripheral blood
smear, and this is because
the splenic macrophages are
actually going to take bites
out of the red blood cell
membrane and change the
shape. You're also going to
see splenomegaly, right?
We have an increased rate
of these splenic macrophages
kind of attacking red
blood cells. They're going
to increase in size because
they're just consuming more.
You're going to have an
elevated unconjugated bilirubin
level and this is again
due to the extravascular
breakdown of hemoglobin.
And finally, because of this
increase in unconjugated
bilirubin, you will see
jaundice and increased risk
of gallstones. And this
again all goes back to that
breakdown of hemoglobin as
the protoporphyrin is broken
down into unconjugated
bilirubin. And again, the
general cause of extravascular
hemolysis is usually due
to alterations that make
the red blood cells less
deformable, right? They're
not as flexible, so they
actually can't move through
the splenic sinusoids as well,
where they get trapped,
and those macrophages, once
they're trapped, will go
eat those red blood cells.
So in comparison,
intravascular hemolysis is
destruction within the
blood vessel itself,
right? It's not in the
spleen, in the macrophages,
it's actually occurring
within the vessels.
And because of this,
you're actually going to
see free hemoglobin
circulating in the blood
vessels, which eventually
binds to haptoglobin.
Haptoglobin picks up
the hemoglobin and helps
excrete it. This is
important to keep in
mind when we think about
our clinical findings.
So for our clinical
findings, you're going to see
schistocytes on peripheral
blood smear, and these again
are just kind of damaged
red blood cells. They were
beat up either by calcified
vessels or maybe an
autoimmune attack. You could
have hemoglobinemia, which
essentially is just free
hemoglobin circulating
in the blood. You could also
see hemoglobinuria, which
is that hemoglobin that was
in the blood, go through
the kidneys, and be
filtered out into the urine.
So you're going to see free
hemoglobin in the urine.
You also may see hemosodonuria,
which is hemoceterin,
which is the iron plus
the protein in the urine.
Again, when we think
about hemoglobin,
it could be broken
down into its parts.
The renal cells will
essentially pick up the
hemoglobin and break it down
into iron. the iron binds
to the proteins in the
renal cells and will
actually be stored and
eventually these tubular
cells will be shed resulting
in the hemocetinuria.
And you're going to see
actually a decrease in
serum haptoglobin and
this is because once the
haptoglobin is bound to the
free hemoglobin it will be
removed from circulation.
So we have an increase
of intravascular lysis
we're going to see increased
free hemoglobin in the
blood therefore the
haptoglobin is going to go
do its job, pick up this
hemoglobin and be excreted
from the circulation.
Some general causes to
keep in mind. Mechanical
injuries, complement fixation,
intracellular parasites such
as malaria, and we could
also have toxic factors.
When we think about mechanical
injury, you can think
about maybe prosthetic
cardiac valves. We could also
have narrowing of circulation
due to maybe thrombi,
and also you may see
hemoglobinuria in repetitive
physical trauma such as like
a marathon runner. If you
test urine from a marathon
runner because of the constant
pounding on their legs,
you actually may see a
little bit of hemoglobin.
It also could be complement,
which is more IgM that
can activate complement,
which will Lysed the
cell within the vessel.
So I know we spoke a
little bit more about extra
and intravascular hemolytic
anemias, but I want to
focus on segmenting out
these anemias that we're
going to learn as intrinsic,
meaning there's an
issue with the red blood cell
itself, versus extrinsic,
meaning something else
is going on. There's a
nice little mnemonic for
the intrinsic hemolytic
anemias being MAD. It
could be a defect in the
membrane, abnormal hemoglobin,
or deficient enzymes.
We're going to start
with hereditary
spirocytosis, which
is a membrane defect.
So hereditary spirocytosis,
it's an extravascular
predominant hemolytic
anemia, meaning it's usually
these red blood cells are
removed by the spleen, but
it's an intrinsic anemia,
meaning the issues within
the red blood cell itself.
The pathology, it's an
autosomal dominant trait,
and you usually see defects
in proteins interacting
with the red blood cell
membrane. So these most
common proteins are anchorin,
spectrin, band 3, and protein
4.2. And because of these
defects in the proteins,
the membrane is insufficient
and actually destabilizes
the red blood cells.
This destabilized membrane
will actually create
little blebs that you
can see on the outside of
the red blood cell. These
blebs are shed over time
and this actually decreases
our total membrane
surface area. If you can
see here, we have a large
red blood cell that's normal.
We create these blebs,
and over time you lose
these blebs, and it actually
changes the shape. So because
we have a decreased total
membrane, we lose our
biconcave shape, seeing this
round spiroocyte type cell.
And again, if you guys
remember, I really harped
on this biconcave shape,
causing that area of central
pallor in part one. So
if we look here, we lose
surface membrane, we can no
longer have this nice
concave shape and because we
need to fit the same amount
of hemoglobin essentially
in less surface area we
create this nice spherical
cell and we no longer see
the central area of pallor.
Once we see these
spirocytes formed they're
usually removed by the
reticulo-endothelial system
in the spleen as these
spirocytes aren't as
flexible because they
really can't bend through
these small sinusoids
as well so the
macrophages are going to
pick them up and eat them.
So some of the clinical
findings we would expect to
see with the hereditary
spirocytosis are going to include
spirocytes. And again, we
talked about that. They
don't have that central area
of pallor. We're going to
see an increase in RDW.
Again, just because we have
different sized red blood
cells, right? Some of them
are normal size. Some of
them are the spirocytes. This
increase in variability is
going to increase our RDW.
The increase in mean
corpuscular hemoglobin
concentration is again because
we lose some of our surface
area. We lose some of
our total volume of the
cell. However, the hemoglobin
concentration stays
fairly stable, so we're
going to have an increase in
that concentration of
hemoglobin. You're going to
see the classic signs of
extravascular hemolysis,
your splenomegaly jaundice
elevated on conjugated
bilirubin, and you also
may see gallbladder stones.
Some of the
complications to keep in
mind, you can have
an increased risk of
aplastic anemia due
to paravirus B19.
for diagnosis you actually
can do a osmotic fragility
testing so you place these
spirocytes in a hypotonic
solution the water rushes
into the cell and because
we have these defects in
the membrane structure
which is the underlying
underlying reason for this
hereditary spirocytosis
you'll actually see red blood
cell lysis for treatment you
can perform a splenectomy
to resolve the anemia
right this is mostly an
extravascular hemolytic
anemia so if we take out the
spleen we actually can stop
this anemia from occurring
because we won't eliminate
the red blood cells.
You will see spirocytes
and howl jowl bodies on
peripheral blood smear
and these howl jowl bodies
are actually due to
the fragmented nuclear
material in the red blood
cells. Typically the spleen
removes these but once
you have the splenectomy
this will no longer be
the case and these howl
jowl bodies will appear
as small dark dots on the
peripheral blood smear
as you can see up here.
So microbiocorrelations.
The spleen is very important
for fighting infection by
encapsulated pathogens.
So that mnemonic SHIN,
Streptococcus pneumoniae,
Haemophilus influenzae, and
Neisseria meningitidis, right?
So if you have an individual
with a splenectomy,
whether that's an autosplenectomy
or a surgery, they
are at an increased risk
for these three pathogens.
We're going to continue on
with our membrane defects,
the next being paroxysmal
nocturnal hemoglobinuria.
So this is also an
intrinsic anemia,
but this is actually
intravascular,
meaning that this lysis
occurs within the blood
vessel. The pathology behind
it is actually a defect
in the myeloid stem cells.
You see an absent GPI
protein, leaving the cell
susceptible to destruction by
complement. Essentially
what GPI does is it anchors
decay accelerating factor
on the surface of the
red blood cells to protect
them against complement.
I know that was a
lot of complex, very
long words, so
let's break it down.
Decay accelerating factor will
actually inhibit C3 convertase.
Decay accelerating
factor is also known
as CD55, and if we
have an absence of GPI,
we don't have decay
accelerating factor.
Therefore, this decay
accelerating factor
is no longer around
to stop the complement
from being activated.
So in a nutshell, no
GPI allows the complement
to be activated.
GPI also anchors membrane
inhibitor of reactive
lysis, or MIRL, to
protect them against
complement. And MIRL
is also known as CD59.
So typically, this occurs
more often at night.
And this is actually
because complement
is actually just more
active at night due to
the mild respiratory
acidosis during sleep.
Decay accelerating factor
protects against complement
activation, and this is
because C3 convertase leads
to the C5b to the C9 membrane
attack complex. So again,
it's all again due to that
decay accelerating factor
blocking the C3 convertase.
The defect may affect
other myeloid precursor cells
along with the red blood
cells, so you can think
about platelets and white
blood cells. And again,
here's your C3 convertase,
which usually is blocked by
decay accelerating factor.
So for presentation,
there's actually a clinical
triad. It's a Coombs negative
hemolytic anemia, and we'll
discuss that a little bit
more. It's pancytopenia.
Again, it affects all
myeloid precursors. You also
will see a venous thrombosis
due to the platelet
destruction. Some other
findings include hemoglobinuria
and hemoglobinemia. Again,
this is because it's an
intravascular hemolysis. You
also may see hemosiderosis
a few days after the
hemolysis, again because of
the iron, and you may see
red slash pink urine in the
mornings, and this is again
due to the hemoglobin.
Some complications, usually
the main cause of death
is typically from a
thrombosis of the hepatic
portal or cerebral veins.
The platelets release the
cytoplastic contents into
the circulation, causing
thrombosis. It's also
associated with aplastic anemia
and acute leukemia.
For the diagnosis, they
actually perform a flow
cytometry where they will show
absence CD55, which is
the K-accelerating factor,
and CD59, which is
MIRL. For treatment, you
could have anti
-immunologics, so eclizumab,
which targets the terminal
complement protein
C5, so we stop the membrane
attack complex from
forming further down
the reaction pathway.
So now we're moving
on to the abnormal
hemoglobins of intrinsic
hemolytic anemia,
our first being
sickle cell anemia.
Okay, so for sickle cell
disease and sickle cell anemia,
again, this is an intrinsic
anemia, meaning there's
an issue with the cell itself,
but it's an extravascular
hemolysis, again, meaning
the spleen is doing
most of the work for removing
the red blood cells. So
it's an autosomal recessive
mutation in the beta globin
chain of hemoglobin. The
amino acid substitution
is usually the underlying
cause. You have glutamatic
acid, which is hydrophilic,
being replaced by a
valine, which is hydrophobic,
due to a mutation in DNA.
And because of this, you
have the abnormal folding,
causing the aggregation of
hemoglobin. And again, kind
of like beta thalassemia,
the carrier trait is actually
an evolutionary, you know,
protective state against
malaria. And you'll see
almost 10% of all individuals
with African descent being
carriers of sickle cell.
However, the actual
disease arises is when we
have two abnormal beta
globin genes being present.
And again, this is a little
bit different compared
to thalassemia because we
still have beta globin.
So hemoglobin S,
kind of this abnormal
hemoglobin, is still comprised
of the 2 alpha 2 beta,
but now these beta chains
do not fold correctly.
And in individuals with
the two abnormal beta
globin chains, you
usually see about 90%
HBS of being the total
amount of hemoglobin.
the true issue really arises
when we have deoxygenization
of the hemoglobin S
molecules so these molecules
will actually stack into
polymers creating needle
-like fibers and this stacking
creates that classic sickle
shape you see this increased
risk of cycling when
you have hypoxemia dehydration
and or acidosis so you'll
see this extensive damage
occur and this can also
irreversibly sickle the cell
regardless of the oxygen
state and typically one
last thing kind of like beta
-thalcemia sickle cell
disease will not appear in a
newborn infant and this is
again because HBF does not
have a beta chain in it right
it's two alpha two gamma
chains and that high HBF
those first few months of
life is actually protective
and you'll kind of see this
first sickle cell crisis
or sickle cell first arise
in an infant at around six
to nine months of birth.
So to reiterate, we have
an intrinsic anemia with
both extravascular and
intravascular components. And
remember, over time, the
sickling irreversibly damages
the red blood cell
membranes. Our extravascular
hemolysis usually occurs with
the reticular endothelial
system, removing the
damaged red blood cell
membranes and the sickled
cells. You also will kind of
see these red blood cells
become sickled in the spleen
and the bone marrow where we
have hypoxic environments.
And again, you'll see
these classic symptoms,
anemia, jaundice, unconjugated
hyperbilirubinemia,
gallstones, and splenomegaly.
There's also an intravascular
hemolysis component.
These sickling cells lead
to overall just membrane
damage over time, leaving
the red blood cells
mechanically fragile and more
susceptible to hemolysis.
So you'll see these classic
intravascular signs.
Decreased haptoglobin
because it has to pick up the
free hemoglobin in the
blood. You'll also see
hemoglobinemia meaning increased
hemoglobin in the blood and
hemoglobin urea meaning
there's hemoglobin in the
urine in addition our marrow
is going to be in overdrive
to try and respond to this
anemia and produce more
red blood cells and as a
result you'll see erythroid
hyperplasia you're going
to have expansion of
hematopoiesis into the skull
and the face and you'll see
your crew cut appearance
on your x-rays as well as
your chipmunk faces both
also seen in beta thalassemia
you'll have extramidulatory
hematopoiesis
within the liver, and
you are at an increased
risk of aplastic
crisis with paravirus.
And the key to all
of this, again, is
being HBS will sickle
in areas of low O2.
That's the underlying cause
for this entire process.
So to talk about some
of the complications,
they all somewhat
make sense when we
again think about
the pathophysiology.
You're going to have
dactylitis, so swollen hands and
feet, due to the vaso
-occlusive infarcts in the bone.
Again, we're going to have
increased sickling rates
in hypoxic environments,
including in the bone marrow.
Dactylitis is actually a
common sign in infants.
You're going to have
autosplenectomy. The spleen
will be enlarged in
childhood due to the red
pulp congestion. Again,
we're trapping more red
blood cells in the
splenic cords and sinuses.
Over time, you're going
to have this chronic
erythnostasis leading to
splenic infarct, fibrosis, and
shrinkage. And you're going
to see how old jolly bodies
again on blood smear.
Again, remember the spleen
usually removes these, and
And this is also similar
to a post-splenectomy and
hereditary spirocytosis.
You're going to have
an increased risk of
infection, again, due
to the autosplenectomy
with your encapsulated
organisms, as
well as salmonella
paratyphi osteomyelitis.
You could have something
called acute chest
syndrome, which is a vaso
-occlusive crisis in the
pulmonary microcirculation.
You'll see individuals
come in with chest pain,
shortness of breath, lung
infiltrates, and it's
actually the most common
cause of death of adults
with sickle cell disease.
You're going to see sickle
cell pain crises, and
this is, again, due to
vaso-occlusive crises due
to episodes of hypoxic
injury and infarct and
ischemia causing the severe
pain. You'll see these
in the bones, liver,
lung, brain, and spleen.
And finally, because,
again, our kidneys is a
lower oxygen environment,
it's hypoxic in nature,
you'll see increased sickling,
and you may see renal
papillary necrosis, and
as a result, you will
see hematuria, which is
just blood in the urine.
so again when we talk about
sickle cell trait we only
have the presence of one
mutated beta globin and you
will have to remember that
the overall deciding factor
about if a red blood cell
will sickle is the actual
concentration of hbs so
in a sickle cell trait
individual hbs is not at that
magic 60 value right it's
only going to be about 55 and
generally it's asymptomatic
we have no anemia and no
sickle cell in usually
general peripheral blood you
still can see sickling in
the renal medulla again we
have an extremely hypoxic
and hypertonic environment
this can lead to micro
infarctions causing microscopic
hematuria and decrease
ability to concentrate urine
so for our lab findings
we're going to see sickle
cell in sickle cell disease
sickle cells as well as
target cells you could see
with sickle cell disease
and trait for screening, you
could use metabisulfite
screen, and it causes the cells
with any amount of HBS to
sickle. For electrophoresis
in sickle cell disease,
you'll see a very high rate
of HBS with a compensation
with HBF and HBA2. With
the trait, you'll see mostly
HBA, right? We have enough
normal beta globin to
compensate with some HBS and
normal amounts of HBA2.
And the treatment, again is
hydroxyurea, and this just
simply increases our HPF.
So just to recap, we have
two main issues. We have
severe anemia, and this
is the red blood cells
undergoing intrinsic
extravascular hemolytic anemia,
but we also have this
vaso-occlusive disease.
Sickle cells can block and
obstruct microcirculation.
This causes ischemia and
pain to the area of the
obstruction. We can also
see this with dactylitis
in children and acute chest
syndrome in adults, and
overall we will see damage
to the organs, right? We
could have renal papillary
necrosis. In the spleen,
we'll see an autosplenectomy
by early adulthood. And
additionally, you'll also
see avascular necrosis.
So we are now going to
move on to hemoglobin C
disease. Again, this is
an abnormal hemoglobin.
And very simply, it's
an autosomal recessive
pathology, and we have a
beta globin mutation. We have
glutamatic acid to lysine
mutation. And as a result,
you'll see these hemoglobin
crystals inside the
red blood cells, and you'll
also see target cells.
Not a lot there. So
we're on our last piece
of this mnemonic of
intrinsic hemolytic anemias,
deficient enzymes,
our first one being
glucose 6-phosphate
dehydrogenase deficiency.
So for G6PD deficiency,
it's mostly an intravascular
predominance, again occurring
within the blood vessels.
It's an X-linked recessive
pathology. We have
decreased half-life of G6PD,
which essentially renders
the red blood cells
susceptible to oxidative stress
if you guys remember g6pd
helps convert nadp to nadph
which will reduce glutathione
and this glutathione
helps protect against
oxidizing agents and this
hemolysis actually occurs
during periods of oxidative
stress so we could think
certain drugs primoquine
dapsone sulfa drugs right
some of our sulfa drugs
we could think about
antibiotics as well as
antimalarials. Also food, a
big buzzword is fababeans.
So you have some variants.
You have the African
variant, which is usually
more mild. You have reduced
half-life of G6PD. You
see mild hemolysis with
oxidative stress. Typically,
you see this hemolysis
in the older red blood
cells just because the
half-life of G6PD is lower,
so they have less G6PD.
The Mediterranean
variant is more severe,
you have markedly
reduced half-life
of G6PD, and you have
severe intravascular
hemolysis with
oxidative stress.
And again, if you look here
on the bottom, I kind of
just tried to simplify
this whole process for you.
So for findings, your
peripheral blood smear are
going to show Heinz bodies
and bite cells. Heinz bodies
are essentially the result
of oxidative stress,
precipitates hemoglobin,
right? So we can see these
little blue pieces, we'll see
precipitates of hemoglobin
the bite cells are
actually the result of the
heinz body so the heinz
bodies are removed by the
spleen where we see these
bite cells we're also going
to see hemoglobinuria
again this is intravascular
we'll see some back pain
because this is nephrotoxic
hemoglobin is nephrotoxic
in general and we're going
to see decreased g6pd
activity for testing we can
actually do a heinz
preparation to screen for the
disease the hemoglobin
precipitate of this heinz body
can only be seen with
this special stain, so we
can't use a right chiasma
stain to see Heinz bodies.
Weeks after the
hemolytic event, we can
do enzyme testing to
see if we have GCXPD
normal activity.
During the hemolytic
event, it actually
could be falsely normal.
So, peruvite kinase deficiency,
another deficient enzyme.
It's an extravascular
hemolysis, but this is still,
again, are intrinsic
anemias. It's an autosomal
recessive, and we think the
PK deficiency being protective
against malaria, kind of
like some of the other
issues that we talked about.
We see a decrease in pyruvate
kinase. This decreases
ATP, and we see rigid red
blood cells. These rigid red
blood cells have a harder
time navigating through
the reticuloendothelial
system. Again, they're more
susceptible to being eaten
up because they can move
through the system slower.
In addition to all these
issues, we actually see a
change in oxygen efficiency.
If you guys remember,
pyruvate kinase is a downstream
aspect in glycolysis, so
2,3-biphosphoglycerate
shunt right by decreasing
pyruvate kinase. We're going
to build up BPG, and if we
build up the BPG, some of
it will be shunted to 2,3
-BPG, which actually increases
the oxygen delivery due
to a rightward shift of the
oxygen dissociation curve
in hemoglobin which we can
again see down there for
our clinical findings it's
going to be a hemolytic
anemia especially in the
newborns and for your peripheral
blood smear you're going
to see burr cells okay we
finished our intrinsic
anemias now we're moving on
to our extrinsic so let's
start now with autoimmune
hemolytic anemia so again
remember from this point forward
everything we're talking
about is an extrinsic
anemia so meaning the red
blood cell is normal, but
something else is going on that's
marking it for destruction.
For autoimmune hemolytic
anemia, the pathology
is typically that antibodies
that recognize these red
blood cells and mark them
for destruction. And we
could actually break it down
into warm and cold types.
For diagnosis, you actually
have to perform a Coombs
antiglobulin test to detect
the antibodies and or
complement on red blood cells
from the patient. So all
autoimmune hemolytic anemias
are Coombs positive. So let's
actually talk a little bit
about this Coombs test.
So the basis for
the Coombs test is
actually to detect the
presence of antibodies
against circulating
red blood cells.
There are two separate
types of Coombs tests.
We could have a direct
antiglobulin test where we
use anti-human globulin,
which is also the Coombs
reagent that's added to the
patient's red blood cells.
If the red blood cells are
coated with the anti-red
blood cell antibody, So,
essentially, if the red blood
cells are already somewhat
marked for destructions,
you'll see this agglutination,
and you use this direct
test for autoimmune hemolytic
anemia. For indirect
antiglobin tests, you're
actually adding normal red blood
cells to the patient's
serum with the Coombs agent.
So, essentially, we're just
using the patient's serum
to see if the antibodies
are present in the serum.
If the red blood
cell is a gluttonate,
we'll deem that the serum has
that anti-red blood
cell antibody.
So for this one, it's used
more for pre-transfusion
testing. And essentially,
if you want to break it down
into simpler terms, direct
Coombs tests if the red
blood cells are coated with
the antibodies, and indirect
Coombs tests if there are
antibodies in the serum.
So there are two separate types
of autoimmune hemolytic anemia.
Warm-up gluttonation is
mostly due to IgG, and
IgG usually causes
extravascular hemolysis.
The causes can kind
of vary. You can have
idiopathic, autoimmune
disorders such as
lupus, certain drugs,
beta-lactams or alpha
-methyldopa, and also
lymphoid neoplasms.
Your treatment is typically
steroids, rituximab,
splenectomy.
Cold gluttonation is
more likely due to IgM.
And IgM and complement
cause red blood cell
gluttonation and
extravascular hemolysis.
The red blood cells can
deactivate complement,
but C3B acts as an
obstinate in the spleen.
So again, we kind of talked
about complement activation
before, right? The red
blood cell has these
factors that can stop this
complement from going on.
but even so, once it's
marked by C3B as well as IgM,
it will be sent once it
goes to the spleen for
destruction as the macrophages
will identify that IgM.
It's called cold agglutination
typically because
you see it more often
with exposure to the cold,
especially in the limbs.
So in a clinical vignette,
you may see painful blue
fingers and toes caused
by obstruction of
agglutinated red blood cells.
Again, remember, IgM is
a huge molecule, right?
Once they bind to the red
blood cells, IgM may actually
bind to one another,
causing this agglutination
and actually could cause
infarcts. The causes,
kind of think again, M
&M, mycoplasma pneumonia,
infectious mononucleosis,
and also chronic
lymphocytic leukemia.
Nice little mnemonic, warm
and gooey cookies, meaning
warmaglutination and
IgG, go with cold milk,
coldaglutination and IgM.
For treatment of
coldaglutination, you can
think about cold avoidance
as well as rituximab.
So for lab findings,
again, you're going to see
spirocytes. It's a similar
action as hereditary
spirocytosis. Macrophages
will actually perform a
partial phagocytosis of the
red blood cell membrane,
kind of just biting off
pieces of the red blood cell
membrane that are marked
with that IgM or IgG. Because
we have that decreased
membrane amount, we're going
to have these spirocytes
form. Again, our volume
stays somewhat similar,
but our surface area will
decrease. And spirocytes are
eventually sequestered and
destroyed in the spleen. You
could also see agglutinated
red blood cells on the
peripheral blood smear.
Again, remember, the antibodies
can bind together and
create these larger blobs.
So we see this agglutination
up here as well as some
of these spherocytes so
we have macro and micro
angiopathic hemolytic anemia
and these are essentially
intravascular hemolysis
so these occur within the
blood vessel but they are
both extrinsic anemias so
macro angiopathic hemolytic
anemia think macro big
structures they're usually
secondary to mechanical
destruction of the red
blood cells the causes can
include prosthetic heart
valves aortic stenosis and
on peripheral blood smear
you'll see schistocytes and
these usually are caused
by mechanical destruction
of the red blood cells
microangiopathic think
more micro level right
smaller obstructed or narrow
vessels and the red blood
cells are typically
damaged trying to squeeze
through you can see this
in hypertensive emergency
as well as in some of
these other causes down
below that you'll learn
about as you continue you on
in your medical school
education. For peripheral
blood smear you'll also
see schistocytes and again
this is just caused by
mechanical destruction.
You could also
have drug-induced
hemolytic anemia and it's
very similar to almost
the antibody or
autoimmune type, right? So
you'll have extra and
intravascular hemolysis. It's
most commonly due to
antibody-mediated immune
destruction of red blood
cells. It can be due to
oxidative injury due to
free radicals as well.
Some of your causes
include antibodies,
NSAIDs, and immuno
or chemotherapy.
For your lab findings,
you'll see spirocytes. Again,
they represent the immune
-mediated destruction.
Think again back that we're
marking these red blood
cells with antibodies that
attach to the drug on the
surface. And once that occurs,
the spleen will kind of
phagocytize parts of those
membranes. You'll also see
bite cells, but these
represent more of the oxidative
hemolysis. Again, we want
to remove that oxidative
stress that precipitates
hemoglobin as Heinz bodies.
We could also see infectious
causes. So things like
malaria and bobebsiosis,
both cause intravascular
hemolysis. For malaria, you
see infection of the red
blood cells and liver with
plasmodium. The red blood
cells will eventually
rupture as part of the normal
plasmodium life cycle, causing
the intravascular hemolysis.
On a test question,
think about cyclic fever,
right? daily or every other
day, this can cue you in.
For babesiosis, it's actually
transmitted by tick bite,
and they also infect red
blood cells. The red blood
cells will rupture, causing
a mild hemolytic anemia,
as well as fever, chills,
malaise. You have a higher risk
of severe illness in
asplenic patients, and your
keywords for this disease is
Maltese cross and red blood
cell in anyone living in
the Northeast United States.
So finally, I want to
talk about our anemia of
underproduction. Again, this
is our reticulocyte under 3%,
meaning the bone marrow is
not functioning. So again,
our basic principles for
anemia of underproduction,
we'll see this decreased
reticulocyte count because the
body is not really able to
produce enough red blood
cells. So some common
etologies, you could see just
the common causes of micro
and macrocytic anemia, right?
If we don't have some of
these precursors like folate
or iron, we may not be
able to produce enough
reticulocytes. We could also
have something with renal
failure, right? EPO is produced
in the interstitial cells
of the kidney, right? If
we lose these cells because
of renal failure, we may
actually have a decrease in
EPO production. Therefore,
the bone marrow is never
getting the signal to start
ramp-up production. You
could also have damage to
bone marrow precursor cells.
Some specifics, a big
one they kind of like to
talk about with a
microbiology tie is parvovirus
b19 it infects the red
blood cell progenitors and
halts erythropoiesis
with our healthy patients
it's usually not a big
concern but if the marrow
is already under duress
such as in sickle cell
cell or thalassemia it can
create an aplastic crisis
and a little buzzword for
you guys when you think
about parvovirus and you
see the term slap cheek
rash that should be something
that jumps out at you
you could also have something
called aplastic anemia
and this is when this
anemia this underproduction
is more widespread than
just the red blood cells
so the hematopoietic stem
cells are actually all
damaged leading to pancytopenia
so we have decreased
in red blood cells known as
anemia we have neutropenia
which is a decrease
in neutrophils and
thrombocytopenia which is a
decrease in platelets and all
this will also be with
the low reticulocyte count
in aplastic anemia you have
destruction and failure
of the marrow some of
our causes can include
radiation, viral agents,
Epstein-Barr, HIV, hepatitis.
You could have something
called Fanconi anemia,
which is essentially an
autosomal recessive defect in
DNA repair, which causes
marrow failure. You kind
of see this presentation
of a short stature, cafe
au lait spots, and thumb
and radial defects, and also
an increased malignancy
because we can't repair
DNA. You get idiopathic
as well as drug causes. On
your lab findings, again,
this is an anemia of
underproduction, So decrease
reticulocyte count, increase
erythropoietin, right?
Because our issue is not
in the kidneys, it's
actually in the bone marrow.
You'll have pancytopenia
with normal cell
morphology. Essentially,
the shape is fine, but
just because we have
destruction of the marrow,
we can't get enough
precursor cells out.
And the bone marrow will be
hypocellular with
fatty infiltration.
In your presentation,
again, fatigue, malaise,
pallor, purpura, and
eucosal bleeding.
so we're done with anemias
right everything after
this is essentially
things we already covered
if you guys don't want
to watch these next few
little parts it essentially
just reviews some of
the big characteristics
and shapes of the red
blood cells there are
questions after this as well
so for our red blood cell
shapes i'm not going to
go through each one but
this is here really for you
guys as a quick sheet to
kind of go over some of
the different shapes of
the red blood cells, you'll
come to see a lot of test
questions really love to
give you these kind of
keywords. They won't give
you more buzzwordy things.
They may even give you a
peripheral blood smear
with some of these images.
So again, same thing with
red blood cell inclusions.
I broke it up into
the marrow and the
peripheral blood smears.
Again, this also includes
some microcytic anemias,
right? I included our iron
granules. We also have
peripheral blood smear
findings as well. And
again, I don't want to go
through each one because
I'm not really going to
add anything that isn't
already on the slides.
Here's our summary.
And now we're going
to do some questions.
So question one, 24
-year-old male presents
with a history of fatigue,
yellow skin, upper
left quadrant pain,
physical examination,
reveals jaundice and
splinomegaly. The patient
also notes that his father
diagnosed with a type
of hemolytic anemia.
Peripheral smear reveals
spirocytes with increased
fragility when placed in
a hypotonic solution.
Which one of the following
is the most likely
cause of this patient's
condition? So we first need
to kind of identify what
is going on, what's the
underlying cause, right?
So we could see kind of
like jaundice, plenomegaly,
okay, maybe I'm thinking
of extravascular hemolytic
anemia, right? These are
kind of those symptoms.
Father was also
diagnosed. Okay,
so there's some
genetic component.
Peripheral smear shows
spirocytes, increased
fragility, hypotonic solution.
This really sounds like
hereditary spirocytosis.
Okay, so I know that, but
this doesn't really help
with my answer choices.
So do we think
it's an autoimmune
destruction of red blood cells?
Not really.
I don't, you know, I could
see spirocytes, but I
don't really see this
hypotonic solution lysis.
Defect in CD55 and 159.
No, that's more paroxysmal
nocturnal hemoglobinemia
or urea, so I
don't really think I'll
see that in this case.
G6PD deficiency, I'd
want to see those
Heinz bodies on a
peripheral smear,
right, as well as
bite cells, so no.
And defect in spectrin,
okay, I'm thinking hereditary
spirocytosis. I know
it's an underlying
protein issue, so maybe
that's it. Defect in the beta
chain of hemoglobin i
don't think this is sickle
cell or a thalassemia
so the correct answer is
d defect in spectrum which
is one of the membrane
proteins that you see a
defect in in hereditary
spirocytosis question two
14 year old boy is brought
to the clinic because
the yellow discoloration
of his eyes for one day
this developed at four
days after he had a two
-day illness marked by fever
and water diarrhea
laboratory studies show your
hemoglobin is low hematocrit
is low, your platelet
count is normal, your
luteocyte count is normal,
reticulocyte count is elevated,
indirect belly rubin
is also elevated.
Direct Coombs test is
negative, peripheral
blood smear with crystal
violet shows standing
below. Which of the
following is most likely
underlying mechanism of
this patient's anemia?
Okay, again, what do
I see in this photo,
okay, I kind of see
these, you know,
maybe cells over here,
could be maybe Heinz bodies,
this 14-year-old,
so, you know, I don't
necessarily see a lot of
bite cells, but okay, so
IgM and complement attached
to red blood cells,
Coombs negative, so
that immediately rules
out any form of autoimmune
hemolytic anemia,
decrease ability to reduce ROS,
I like it, inherited defect in
No, again, this is hereditary
spirocytosis. I don't
really see spirocytes,
right? And if I did see
spirocytes, I shouldn't be
seeing these little things.
So again, an inherited
defect causing misfolding
of beta chains. I'm
thinking sickle cell with
this. I don't see any
sickling in consumption
of lead. He's not really
presenting with any
of those classical
symptoms of lead poisoning.
So again, with this, I'm
going to go with B, right?
So given this patient's
glial icterus and laboratory
findings of anemia and
elevated indirect bilirubin
in the setting of a recent
illness, he's probably
experiencing acute hemolytic
anemia. With the blood
smear, you really should
be thinking maybe this is a
G6PD deficiency, right? I
see these Heinz bodies, one
of the underlying causes
of a, you know, hemolytic
or oxidative crisis with
G6PD deficiency is illness.
And if you guys want a
further explanation, there
is a little bit more
information in the notes.
So question three, 72-year
-old woman comes to the
clinic because of a three
-month history of fatigue
who lives alone over the
past six months, been
consuming a diet mostly
of tea, bread, and cheese
due to financial concerns.
She doesn't drink or
take any medications.
Physical exam, she has
conjunctival pallor. Rest
of physical exam discloses
no abnormalities. CBC is
the following. Hemoglobin
is low, hematocrit is
low, MCV is macrocytic,
platelet count is okay,
and so is leukocyte count.
Which of the following
additional findings
is most likely to be
seen in this patient?
So do we think that deficits in
proprioception of
vibratory sensation?
Maybe, right? What are
we thinking here? Past
six months, diet of
mostly tea, bread, and
cheese. Okay, so she's
still having dairy,
so I don't think this
is a B12 deficiency,
and also just this is the
past six months. This is
not years and years, so I
should be thinking, okay,
macrocytic doesn't
necessarily tell me that it's
megaloblastic, but kind of based
off the diet and some other
issues that I'm reading in
the vignette, I could be
thinking this is a macrocytic
maguloblastic anemia,
specifically folate deficiency.
So this is more
subacute combined
degeneration. I'd
see that in B12.
Elevated serum levels
of otorotic acid.
I don't think so,
again, because this
is a recent
presentation. She's 72.
Typically, we see
this issue with
failure to thrive in infants.
Heinz bodies on
peripheral blood smear.
That's, you know,
our G6PD deficiency,
oxidative stress. That's
usually a normocytic
anemia, so I'm going
to cross that out.
Deep vein thrombosis.
I know homocysteine,
which is elevated in
folate deficiency,
actually can cause the
thrombosis, increased
risk of ******, and
MI. I'll leave it.
Increased serum
ethylmolonic acid. This
is incorrect.
This is with a B12
deficiency, right? Both
A and E are for B12.
right? We have normal
levels of methylmalonic
acid in folate
deficiency, therefore
being that D is
the correct answer.
Question 4. A 65-year-old
woman presents to her ***
reporting symptoms of generalized
weakness, lightheadedness,
and diarrhea for the past
few months. Also reports
a sensation of pins and
needles in her feet. Medical
history is significant for
hypothyroidism. Physical exam
reveals decreased sensation
to pinprick in her toes
bilateral and a positive
Romberg. Pepsin levels are
normal. This patient most likely
has a deficit in substance
produced by which of the
following types of cells?
Okay, you could read this
question and go, what the
heck is this even talking
about? So let's break
it down a little bit.
So sensation of pins and
needles in her feet, maybe
a neuropathy, right? Okay.
Medical history is significant
for hypothyroidism as
well. So maybe there's some
form of autoimmune issue.
So maybe I'm
thinking this is some
form of like pernicious anemia.
And if you guys remember
going down the list, the issue
with pernicious anemia is
we lose parietal cells,
right? And we don't have
our intrinsic factor. So the
correct answer here is going
to be E. Pernicious anemia
causes vitamin B12 deficiency,
resulting in a macrocytic
anemia, as well as
peripheral neuropathy. And we
usually see pernicious anemia
being caused by autoimmune
destruction of the parietal
cells, which decreases
our intrinsic factor. Again,
if you want a little bit
more information on this,
read the notes of this slide.
So, question five. A 19
-year-old female comes
to clinic, complains of
fever, chills, malaise,
fatigue, joint pain.
Earlier this week, she
had a bright red rash
on her face, describing
it as almost a slap
-cheek type of appearance.
She's been in and out
of the hospital multiple
times throughout her
childhood for sickle cell
pain crises and is on a
stable dose of hydroxyurea.
She states this does
not feel like another
exacerbation of her
sicker cell. CBC shows the
following. Hemoglobin's
low, hematocrit's low,
reticulate site count is
actually elevated, MCV is
90, platelet count's 100,
and leukocyte count is 4
,000. And my apologies,
platelet count is 100,000.
What acute event
is causing this
patient's acute presentation.
Okay, so we have a couple
things here. This is an
individual with chronic
sickle cell, right? Her bone
marrow is already under
duress, and she came into
the clinic with kind of these
symptoms, fever, chills,
malaise, fatigue, joint
pain, slap cheek, rash.
Okay,
maybe this is some form of like
anemia of
underproduction, right?
Parvovirus, aplastic crisis.
So let's look at some of
our values. Our hemoglobin
is low, our hematocrit is
also low, very low, right?
It's almost, you know,
three times under the
normal. Our reticulocyte
count at baseline is actually
elevated, which is
interesting, right? And under
production, we wouldn't
expect this. MCV is normal,
our platelet count is low,
our leukocyte count is
also low. So we should
almost be seeing like kind of
this pancytopenia picture,
which we would expect.
However, if we actually
look at the corrected
reticulocyte count,
right, 6% divided by,
or actually, my
apologies, multiplied
by the hematocrit, which is 15
over 45, to get our
corrected count,
if this actually becomes
2%, right? Because 6 divided
by 3, or 6 times 1 over
3, which is essentially
6 divided by 3, is 2. So
we can actually say our
reticulocytes are not
appropriately responding, right?
The bone marrow is not
working correctly. So this
value actually becomes
2%. So now we can kind of
think about this as an
aplastic crisis. If we read
the description of this of
the vignette right fever
chills joint pain slap
cheek rash she's already at
a high risk for this form
of aplastic anemia i would
most likely say the
acute event causing this
patient's acute presentation
is a parvo virus b19 okay
our last question 19
year old college student
presents her *** with
complaints of fatigue
malaise lymphadenopathy
states her roommate has
been presenting with similar
symptoms for the past
few weeks physical exam
is negative for any
cardiovascular respiratory
abnormalities but
splenomegaly is seen on
exam patient also states
pain and paleness in our
hands when walking outside
in the winter without
gloves cbc and a peripheral
blood smear are performed
with the results below so
our hemoglobin's low
reticulocyte count is normal mcv
is normal rdw is normal
and the leukocyte count is
elevated what is the
pathophysiology of this patient
all right let's kind of
go through the vignette
fever malaise lymphadenopathy
she's a college student
her roommate has presenting
with similar symptoms
maybe this is a cold
until i come to read
splenomegaly right maybe
i'm thinking this is some
form of mononucleosis
it's very common in the
college age student she
had a close sick contact
and when we look at it
our leukocyte count is
very elevated when we
look at our blood smear
We see these spirocytes.
We also see a gluttonation.
So what's the underlying
pathophysiology? We
should be thinking
autoimmune hemolytic anemia,
right? This isn't necessarily
an underproduction.
If we look at our
reticulocyte count,
they don't even give us a
hematocrit, so we have to
assume it's normal. So
underproduction is not an issue.
I don't think this
is a chronic disease.
You know, typically
you'd see, you know,
a MCV that's lower with
anemia of chronic disease,
things like that, not necessarily
in that state, although
it's something to keep
in mind. Membrane defect,
again, you see it with
spirocytes, hereditary
spirocytosis, but I don't
necessarily think with this fatigue,
malaise, and lymphadenopathy
that this is probably
the best answer. So we're
kind of now left between
the autoimmune hemolytic
anemias due to IgG or IgM.
So for IgG antibodies,
remember it's warm and gooey.
We think warm agglutination
and typically we don't
think about mononucleosis
or infectious causes causing
warm autoimmune hemolytic
anemia. We think about it
more with cold IgM antibodies,
right? IgM also has a
higher rate of agglutination,
can cause some intravascular
occlusion as well. So
the correct answer here
is actually going to be b
autoimmune hemolytic anemia
due to igm antibodies so
here are my references so
this is our last slide
again i hope these lectures
were easy to understand
i know there's a lot
of material and i know
these are somewhat longer
lectures but this is a
very highly tested topic
once you get the boards
and it's something
you see in so many
patients so again guys
please if you have
any questions at all,
please feel free to
email me. We can set
up Zooms. We can meet
in groups. Also, if
you see me around the
old Westbury campus,
please feel free to
just pull me aside.
You know, let me know
what you thought about the
lecture. You can also email
me your thoughts if you
have any questions at all.
And please, please, please,
I know you're all very
busy, but I would love a
little bit of feedback on
this lecture. I wish you
guys the best of luck on
your next comp and the rest
of your semester. I hope
you guys are all doing well.
Keep up the really hard
work. I know first year is
very very difficult but
I'm sure all you guys are
doing amazing. Have a great
day and again please feel
free to reach out with
any questions. Thank you.